anie samson luc ferrandez bonsoir j'ai
d'abord vu depuis la fameuse soirée
comment allez vous habillez vous ça va
très bien on va très bien
vous avez eu chaud des cérémonies comme
ça annie élus j'en ai eu que j'en ai eu
six fois le pan dans le souss mandat
c'est toujours impressionnant ça fait
toujours c'est toujours c'est toujours
le fun ce soir et en extrapolant jusque
j'ai semblé comprendre cause de
recomptage ben oui il ya eu des petits
qu'on a vu des anicroches un gendarme
ont rien d endroit où luxe et c'est
normal où je ne me rappelais pas de
grosses erreurs comme celle là mais
c'est arrivé plusieurs fois des
cérémonie d'assermentation que tout le
monde soit présent ça c'est arrivé non
mais c'est parce qu'il y avait des
reportages mais celle là cette fois ci
la un pour moi j'ai jamais vu ça de ma
vie aussi bas par l'élection de 2005 où
il y avait le vote électronique mais
c'est le 39 comme ceux où on a aussi
trompé de colonne haye est certainement
quelqu'un qui a fait son travail
correctement ok on va voir la suite des
choses madame plantes commence son
mandat avec une histoire épouvantable on
en parle depuis dimanche soir du meurtre
de ce jeune garçon de 16 ans en pleine
rue
là c'est rendu que l'école le cas ni
demande aux parents de dire alors enfin
dix ou douze adolescents élèves ne
rentrait pas seul par le parc le prenez
la rue éclairé est ce qu on en est rendu
là luc mais écoute ce c'est un signe de
ghettoïsation on n'a pas ça dans une
ville qui fonctionne bien de dire aux
enfants éviter le parc évitez de sortir
la nuit
j'imagine que dans cet esprit la
directrice et pour quelques semaines le
temps que ça se calme mais c'est un
signe dangereux et inquiétant est
effectivement mois ci chez les parents
d'un adolescent
qui ferait 4 et sparte là je lui dirais
de ne plus y aller puis je dirais de
rentrer tôt aussi c'est inquiétant oui
et annie sait on parle de montréal en
partie car ses cinq chaînes en parle du
quartier où je suis né puis où j'ai été
maire pendant plusieurs années c'est un
quartier
c'est un quartier où on avait mis en
place une structure pour s'occuper des
jeunes ont pas souvent dire maintenant
la vie du budget c'est la mode il faut
convaincre les groupes communautaires
faut qu'on fasse de prévention mais la
prévention demain matin changeront rien
ceci est une prévention qui doit se
faire sur un teint il faut prendre les
rencontres et les jeunes asseyez d'avoir
la confiance donc oui la prévention vaut
pouvoir rejouer un rôle extrêmement
important pour les prochaines
générations pour les générations
actuelles
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment de la
répression c'est la police et on n'est
plus là pour aller dire bonjour aux
jeunes puis soyez gentil là les armes à
feu circulent beaucoup on en a déjà
parlé patrice et luc les armes à feu
maintenant les jeunes en ont partout
comme ils veulent des enfants tombent
ils font ça sur leurs imprimantes 3d
puis peuvent sortir avec sa s'est assis
là ils nous font de la police nous en
faut plus il faut plus de surveillance
il faut qu'on règle ce problème
rapidement parce que plus on va attendre
plus les jeunes vont prendre le terrain
année tu sais que la police ne règleront
rien la police à intervenir peu calmé le
jeu puis intervenir si la violence mais
comme quand un phénomène de
ghettoïsation comme seul espace qui se
prépare depuis 20 ans puis les fines les
éléments clés de cette ghettoïsation là
c'est d'abord l'école sait comment ça se
fait qu'on a laissé des taux de
décrochage est parce que le groupe
communautaire qui va agir sur le pour
canaliser l'énergie des jeunes vers
autre chose c'est important les budgets
mon passé de 3,5 millions de dollars
c'est bien mon par deux à 5 millions de
dollars si on veut vraiment régler la
situation la situation c'est un l'école
2 les parents de ces enfants là souvent
des mères monoparentales débordée qui on
peut vraisemblablement pas tous les
moyens de contrôler leurs enfants de
l'île de les encadrer alors aider ces
personnes là au quotidien et agir sur
l'école puis agir sur les jeunes mais
comme tu le dis quand on va avoir fait
ces trois choses là on en a pour des
années avant que ça se sache se
normalise pas ce que lol et les parents
les parents des parents était interviewé
aujourd'hui on a pensé ça plutôt qu'ils
faisaient là c'est cette partie de ping
pong entre le québec et le fédéral à la
mer sur les armes à feu là on en a assez
que c'est pas mal plus complexe que
chaque année mais là il faut que les
gouvernements mettent leur cul là rien
de leurs responsabilités parce que c'
est l' affaire de tous on parle de
saint-michel aujourd'hui mais on a eu 30
oct avant le grand début d'année qui
touche rivière des prairies le sud ouest
le centre ville le plateau qui touche
partout la situation de saint michel
c'est que le berceau des gangs de rue a
recommencé l'ancien shea au une
trentaine d'années donc ça michel il
berceau mais ce qui fait que c'est la
ghettoïsation luc chaput jeux plus ou
moins d'accord parce qu'on parle de
qualité de vie on parle d'un quartier
qui sont pauvres on parle des jeunes qui
souvent comme tu dis monoparentales mais
qui n'ont pas les moyens l'école fait ce
qu'ils peuvent dans saint michel on a
tous les organismes communautaires
l'arrondissement n'est pas qu'on me dise
où on a investi dans les médiateurs
urbains dans les patrouilleurs aller aux
écoles à chaque sortie d'école on est
des patrouilleurs qui sont là des
patrouilleurs les organismes
communautaires sur toi faut joseph
françois perrault qui accompagne les
jeunes qui parlent aux jeunes qui les
occupent qui les empêchent d'être
entrent dans des gangs puis ça
fonctionne bien mais ce qu'il faut c'est
que ça fonctionne partout comme ça dans
les autres arrondissements parce que le
ce des bornes et la police son travail
dans ces situations que c'est vrai
patrouiller mais aussi par l'agression
mais ce que la vérité puis le chef de la
police
monsieur car on l'a dit cette semaine à
accompagner la mairesse le qu'il a dit
c'est pas normal que des jeunes de 15 16
ans des hommes comme ceux à qui il a
presque dit très clairement dire on est
dépassé par ce phénomène lol oui
absolument mais moi je comprends que la
police s'intéresse aux armes l'appui que
la police veuille contrôler les armes et
qu'elle sait le déplore la décision du
fédéral de remettre ça sur le dos des
fédés à des municipalités de pause en
étant en intercepter suffisamment la
frontière je comprends ça mais il ya
quelqu'un qui la tient cette arme là
c'est la matière pas tout seul je
comprends que romero mélo mais le
projecteur sur les armes parce qu'il ya
de plus qu'il y en avait avant mais le
le jeune qui est mort dans qu'est mort à
la station snowdon y était assassiné
avec un coup de couteau avec des coups
de couteau et au lendemain de cet
assassinat là il y avait un jeune qui
fêtait sur youtube avec la musique rap
qu'un site comme s'ils étaient dans sa
hotte chicago alors une culture ça a
changé il ya de l'investissement à faire
sur ces jeunes là bien au delà du
contrôle des armes oui c'est exactement
et c'est une culture comme vous dites il
ya des rivalités qu'on a peine à
imaginer en deux clans deux gagnants
deux et ça donne ce que ça donne et donc
à une compréhension avoir beaucoup plus
puis une désinformation on est comme
déconnecté même si beaucoup de groupes
communautaires dans votre quartier
manifestement on est comme déconnecté
non non mais mais nous on avait quand
même il y avait la police qui travaille
avec les organismes communautaires avec
les élus locaux avec les écoles donc
avait déjà certes d'ex passait quelque
chose le message et les informations
circulent et ce qu'on voit pas ailleurs
ailleurs la police parce que sa job il
faut vraiment qu contacté tout le monde
un arrondissement là ça se passe
ensemble et ça c'est surtout le défaut
qu'on a eus ailleurs dans deux
arrondissements et l'halogène ce qu'il
faut aussi qu'ils se promènent d'un
arrondissement à l'autre et là il y en a
qui a été tuée maintenant tout dépend
dans quel secteur il y en a un autre
dans le prochain secteur qui va se faire
dire aussi ça c'est comme ça c'est pour
ceux que la police maintenant le doit
jouer un rôle vraiment de répression
camp lejeune desrochers moi je cherchais
je couvrais j'étais journaliste
municipal issigeac chalet sur les lieux
sacrés un état de choc et la police
henri pas les bush et d'obama mais le
boucher de plus contre la guerre des
motards à ses potes là est ce que l'on
n'est pas devant quelque chose qui va
changer des choses le clou absolument
mais j'espère parce que bon déjà ont eu
un premier changement la mairesse
lorsque le plus la parole avant-hier
elle a déclaré que dorénavant bien qu'on
ait beaucoup discuté sur la nécessité de
contrôler le travail de la police le dit
mais peut-être qu'il va falloir revenir
à 2 plus d'intervention elle a dit aussi
que s'il fallait travailler au niveau
judiciaire est légal revenir à certains
mesure qui avait été mise en place par
le gouvernement conservateur de harper
elle allait y songer mais j'aurais voulu
plus que ce soit moi j'aurais voulu plus
que ça j'aurais voulu entendre tolérance
zéro j'aurais voulu entendre qu'elle
interpelle le gouvernement legault le
gougne ne peut pas s'en laver les mains
des écoles où il ya des écoles de 50%
décrochage et où on peut pas enseigner à
la moitié arrière de la classe où les
jeunes décrochent en secondaire 3 ça
c'est inadmissible c'est la base du
problème très bien merci beaucoup nous
avons parlé on va se voir à chaque
semaine merci c'est tout le temps qu'on
anime malheureusement mais on se reparle
très bientôt